beau les séries où j'ai une boîte à
secrets vous êtes tous mais un secret
ici parce que demain il ya le secret de
la potion magique qui sort avec
notamment la voix d'elie semoun etc des
chroniques alors qu'ils ont mis je ne
sais pas du tout de quoi il s'agit elie
vous allez devoir trouver avec les
téléspectateurs qui fait ça il ya
quelqu'un qui a marqué j'éternue quand
je suis excité à votre addictif
d'eternit ont valu tous à bâle était
publicité donc à nos basses et non
d'ailleurs hier soir ça a été un malade
hier soir ça a été violent square sépare
le téléphone et vous répéter tout bah
quoi
oui ça a été oui merci ce quillard il
avait un petit rang petit rendez vous à
18h et annulé
il a été décalé à 21h30 très bien merci
donc j'étais en du coup je suis excité à
votre avis qui était en lui quand il
excite et isa c'est kim et moi je suis
parent de gilles verdez parce qu'il a un
grand nez ah ouais non non non non et
gilles verdez quand ils éternuent quand
c'est la fin du monde reut sa villa
montiel tout c'est moi oui un célèbre
lorsque seulement deux compagnies et que
je suis voilà en excitation jeu à la
goutte au nez vous avez les qualités
vocales mais je mets un peu d'huile
essentielle est la seule au calme bah
oui c'est bon ça qu'est ce qu'il ya
des codes secrets
j'ai eu une aventure avec un ou une
députée dans un avion non ça c'est dit
oui je pense aussi comme jamais pourquoi
on sait que les benjamins c'est moi
j'avais l'aventuré alors vous auriez moi
te dire ça mais je vous aime beaucoup me
line quoi mais qu'est-ce qui est ce que
j'ai une question à vous poser ou qu'on
se pose un petit peu est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas un peu mytho parce que non
mais quoi on m'accepte bas mais c'est la
vérité donc cohérente à utah a couché
avec bachelot nous dire de qui il s'agit
dans un étonnant non sinon ce rac
certaines fois on sait on commence à
vous cernez non c'est bon parce que lui
ça va là haut dit mcdowell ma gueule
non mais attendez top arrêter l'émission
va jeter un problème n'était pas là mais
je vais m'occuper de lui pendant la pub
j'ai encore lui met une thalassémie des
lois c'est la vidéo si vous avez de quoi
de la nasse qu'est-ce qui a vu des
choses alors à l'aéroport on s'ennuyait
un petit peu l'ensam en attendant
l'avion
du coup at elle dit comme d'hab et
arrive dans un vase ifrap mois frappe
moi façon joue un petit peu faible comme
moi il a fait face à vous il s'est pris
une tannée
je suis mobilisation il est un ami 2010
tu l'a arrêté ces bases je suis un ami
très là dedans c'est la bagarre tamesna
rien voilà je vous le dis les
chroniqueurs ont des secrets et je vous
jure j'ai vu des secrets la sans rigoler
alors donc on était sur le secret de
benjamin castaldi qui a dit qu'il avait
eu une aventure avec la développer moi
j'aime areva développé alors c'était sur
un vol qui reliait papeete à paris ap ap
c'est pour vous cette fois le prêtre
s'est passée la porte à côté et j'étais
à côté d'une députée charmante et el mar
politique
alors je crois que c'était plutôt plutôt
à droite le député de l'est
et ça s'est très bien passé pour moi non
mais non mais non mais si elle regarde
bamba sogona mais quand j'étais petit
j'avais un film qui s'était emmanuel
normalement alors je vous dire souvent
les films on s'en fout totalement la
réalité sont prêts nous allons donc
voilà mais non je dirai jamais alors
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans l'avion
dépêché vous énoncez forte bien le
connaissez pas donc vous allez nous
n'avions pas du tout alors d'içi moi il
n'est pas demandé non plus omis de
fulham non mais lui les tours jumelles
moi j'étais à tahiti aussi pour jouer
ces 24 heures d'avion c'est long way
donc tu as le temps de faire
connaissance en 24 rencontres et de
quitter ce jour non mais attendez qu est
ce qui s'est passé vous avez rien fait
ou vous avez jeux sont embrassés on a
fait un peu mais c'était très très
érotique c'est toujours à protéger aulas
vous faites pas papeete paris vous êtes
à côté d'une jeune femme qui est qui ça
fait un nom et il ya escale à los
angeles
oui mais justement datant de voilà les
doit cravacher
[Rires]
il a donné les prix d'un bel outil va
nous faire le trajet way mepha tension
parce que normalement tu traverses quand
roselyne bachelot non non non c'est
vraiment c'était on discute si vous
allez à tahiti donc c'est la députée
laurentides je renais tahiti sa devise
les effectifs ces jeunes femmes ou alors
castaldi je vous le dis où il est devenu
tommy où il nous prend vraiment pour des
cons
j'ai été demandée en mariage à peine
j'ai quoi voulez qu'on a pas bien la
pelle à la main ouais mais ça va là j'ai
dit non bah non mais écoutez vous voulez
vraiment comme idée provient en fait il
va alors attendez cas les loups numéro
cette dame je crois va vous étiez
forcément mariés vous êtes toujours
mariés ou non mais on va on va l'appeler
on va l'appeler j'ai été demandée en
mariage par une personne de 81 9 aura
par isabelle c'est qui non mais à votre
avis c'est qu'ils jouaient maxime guinea
peut-être non à la réunion christine un
sujet clé on se calme
certes ce cas de mathieu aujourd'hui
christine kelly et lil boudet qui j'ai
pas suivi par dont j'essaie de regarder
les séries c'est moi pardon non c'est
vous c'est qui sait vous moi c'est sûr
que c'est géraldine sexy alors sinon oui
c'est moi
le secret c'est comme si moi je dis
dommage ou 16h et mignot nerfs sacre à
bord multi millionnaire et j'avais 16
ans ah ouais quand même
j'ai dit oui parce que je savais pas
comment dire alors à bac 6 nous regarde
vraiment de là où la vie bio là mais là
il n'est pas non plus nous voir on
embrasse vraiment très fort parce que
cette personne aujourd'hui la 281 de vos
bras salut l'artiste m'est il s'appelait
très riche s'appelait comment il
s'appelait harold gelé quoi nul à lyon
et devant là parce qu'on était fou des
arbres tous les deux voila j'aimerais
qu'on voulait empêcher n'a pas un arbre
multiséculaire elle est une fille de 16
ans qui s'intéresse aux armes et qui en
plus est jolie car je les talibans
savaient pas ils savaient pas quoi dire
pour ken quoi et non non et il m'a
demandé en mariage comme savaient pas
comment dire non mais j'ai dit oui oui
et puis je me suis j'ai misé sur
l'avenir et j'avais raison
c'est à dire non en anglais il est
décédé début mai mais tu t'es marianne
qu'il est décédé quand même huit mois
plus tard apple est amer butt est mariée
avec lui
non non non juste envie jouer sur le
temps ouais ouais c'est du bonbon
j'espère qu'il va passer l'armé à gauche
mais il était très drôle
balla bèye gens se massent talent là on
comprenait ce qu'il dit c'est lui qui
nous enferme un premier dentier
on y va abb on était comme ça en laponie
faisait pas comme ça tous les oeufs
oui mais j'avais enlevé mon entier donc
allez c'est pas grave j'ai fais pipi au
lit jusqu'à mon adolescence je gagne
c'est mathieu than avait arrêté de dire
tous et ganila gianni mêmes séances pas
mal tu vois pas en quoi c'est vous je
pense c est quelqu un cap
si j'ai plus rien manqué d'affection ça
ouais tiens de bravo c'est moi c'est
quoi c'est vous j'aime beaucoup ta
réponse oui assez vous dites je manqué
d'affection et je n'ai pas pu aller
jusqu'à l'adolescence c'est vrai chéri
ah ouais c'est vrai il m'a dit ça
j'aurais pas dit pourquoi mais c'est
vrai
alors on va pas vous demander de détails
mais on dit ça arrive moi j'ai fait ça
jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans aujourd'hui on
peut arrêter
j'en ai lu justin je me suis fait pop au
dessus et vous vous êtes fait peau de
son moi j'ai plein de fois bon c'est pas
bon ça ce sont des toilettes à babré
obama et l'hôtel fait beaucoup dans les
toilettes est tout fier de le lire on
dirait qu'elle a accompagné pour moi
mais sinon les toilettes standard et toi
tu es très belle pendant les livraisons
non non non c'est pas moi c'est qui sait
vous osez vous alors je vais pas chez
qui c'est fait pour que tu sais rien
mais lui ça devait être dans une cabine
à uv pour rien senti
[Applaudissements]
mon ami tu connais ne veut pas de
détails version on est mieux peut pas on
peut pas les arrêter
alors quoi y en a juste un jeu m'arrêter
sur un secret le dernier secret de la
soirée matière de laon ont été arrêtés y
en a un qui m'a énervé j'ai volé 50
euros à 6,50 c'est cassady et je vais
vous dire je vais vous dire je pense
savoir de qui il s'agit bah oui je suis
persuadé matière n 128 c'est matthieu
delormeau bangui
alors vous masser dans les 50 euros
alors si on est vraiment dans nos
députés ce soir le secret faux car ces
150 m'a pris trois jours tp la rue il ya
quelqu'un qui veut dire quelque chose
mais je pense que là c'est le moment de
se battre la violence ne résout jamais
nous quoi la racaille sabot se bat non
on n'est pas là pour se faire dire
peut-être emprunter
non alors va emprunter ça fait trois ans
alors dites nous ce qui s'est passé
parce que j'étais pas au courant parce
qu'il faut faute avouée à moitié
pardonnée donc ça veut 75 et jamais je
dis la vérité je vais souvent dans votre
loge rapport au fait qu'on est très
proche l'un et l'autre où on y va tous
et prendre des blousons et c'est vrai
que beaucoup d'habits et à une ou deux
fois tu m'as dit bébé pour un blouson et
alors je les lis probable où l'on ait
pas de bébé je dirai la vérité une
vérité des maisons en et 11 chez moi
mais je remercie beaucoup
mais une fois j'en ai pris un goût me
dis tiens sers toi j'en ai pris un jeu
les minimes allait très bien il était
blanc était magnifique et c'est vrai
qu'en arrivant chez moi chaque année
dans la porte
il y avait trois billets de 50 euros
mais pas les taxer
peut-être que vous n'êtes pas là et
c'est vrai que comme je vous connais
aussi je sais que c'est hyper généreux
et se dit voilà il ya 150 euros tu
meures a dit garder les bébés et que je
voulais pas être coincée éviter de
déranger 5 mai 150 euros c'est énorme
faim trou mais je mets mais j'en ai
conscience et pourtant je les ai gardés
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien ces 150 euros c'est ce qu'on
va faire
les hashtags 150 euros exact j'aimerais
qu'on les offres pour quelqu'un voilà
rien aux racines pas si ou d'ailleurs et
on va nous offrir pour quelqu'un pour
une famille jeanne ya besoin d'acheter
des cadeaux de noël pour les enfants
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire que je ne les ai plus il ya
une tirette non mais je vous le dis bah
c'est une énorme somme et 150 euros pour
acheter mon fils cadeaux achetés close à
moto ou en voiture au son voili voilà
qui pourra c'est pas du vol a vraiment
je me suis dit je pas le déranger avec
ça vous avez beaucoup de responsabilités
tour au stand ans sur la chaîne
je vais pas vous nous embrouiller avec
un texto et ouais j'ai passé riche on
lui mettre la pression moi je rajoute 50
ça fait 200 euros pour lui mettre la
pression qui 52 mois raconte qu'il donne
150 jeunes 50 ça fait 2 120 vers
[Applaudissements]